hello conan o'brien here and uh backed
up by some of my favorite people
master band leader uh guitar wizard
jimmy vavino
helping me out here uh also uh greatest
bass player in the history of the world
mighty mike merritt mr merritt nice to
see you and uh
james the worm wormworth on the wash
tubs back here
best players in the business uh i am
very happy
to be part of the project kids care
telethon
2020 as you know has been a very
difficult year for everybody but
especially for
kids now get this 100 percent
of the money you donate will go to help
underprivileged kids which is amazing
the get together foundation and their
partners provide
food shelter education art mentoring
toys health care and more
donating is so easy just look at the
information
at the bottom of your screen we're gonna
do a little something right now
you can't have the holidays without the
great chuck berries run
run rudolph and uh jimmy why don't you
start us off
you know you're the mastermind all
things
[Music]
down
he said all i want for christmas
[Music]
rudolph is gotta make it to town
santa tell him hurry tell him he can
take the freeway down
run from rudolph i'm breathing like a
[Music]
merry-go-round
run run rudolph
[Music]
i'm feeling like a
drinking wet
[Music]
santa's gotta make it to town
run run
[Music]
so
hey
we just lost a lot of money for charity
sorry kids we'll try harder next time